the effort is enough in life there will
be times when we do everything right
perhaps even perfectly yet the results
will somehow be negative failure
disrespect jealousy or even a resounding
yawn from the world depending on what
motivates us this response can be
crushing when someone works on a project
whether it's a book or a business or
even his/her own behavior at a certain
point that thing leaves their hands and
enters the realm of the world it is
judged received and acted on by other
people it stops being something he
controls and it depends on them will we
work hard for something that can be
taken away from us will we invest time
and energy even if an outcome is not
guaranteed with the right motives we're
willing to proceed with ego were not we
have only minimal control over the
rewards for our work and effort other
people's validation recognition rewards
so what are we going to do not be kind
not work hard not produced because there
was a chance it would be reciprocated
come on
think of all the activists who will find
that they can only advance their cause
so far the leaders who are assassinated
before their work is done the inventors
whose ideas languish ahead of their time
according to society's main metrics
these people were not rewarded for their
work should they have not done it if
that is your attitude how do you intend
to endure tough times what if you're
ahead of the times what if the market
favors some bogus trend what if your box
or your clients don't understand it's
far better when doing good work is
sufficient in other words the less
attached we are to the outcomes the
better when fulfilling our only
standards is what builds us with pride
and self-respect when the effort not the
results good or bad is enough with ego
this is not nearly sufficient no we need
to be recognized we need to be
compensated especially problematic is
the fact that often we get that we are
praised we are paid and we start to
assume the two things always go together
the expectation hangover inevitably
ensues well get ready for it it will
happen maybe your parents will never be
impressed maybe your girlfriend won't
care
maybe the inventor won't see the numbers
maybe the audience won't clap but we
have to be able to push through we can't
let that be what motivates us you will
be unappreciated you will be sabotage
you will experience surprising failures
your expectations will not be met
you will lose you will fail how do you
carry on then how do you take pride in
yourself and your work John Wooden's
advice to his player says it change a
definition of success success is peace
of mind which is a direct result of
self-satisfaction in knowing you make
the effort to do your best to become the
best that you're capable of becoming do
your work do it well then let go that's
all there needs to be
recognition and rewards those are just
extra rejection that's on them not us
ego it seems is a precursor not just a
miserable failure but to being miserable
when we inevitably do fail we need you
to be strong more we need you to be good
and honorable and loyal whether the
incentives aligned with it or not
because it's the right thing to do
because doing it is enough the effort is
enough